[Music]
oh yeah it's the Monday morning spark
with your favorite [ __ ] uncle
we got some tremendous [ __ ] weed fear
we got great news we got everything we
got metal and metal do all in company
uncle Joey here and the Garden of Good
and Evil you bad [ __ ] it's
Monday May 15th the halfway mark what
the [ __ ] have you done you understand me
Detroit I love you for coming out this
weekend Milwaukee I love you for coming
up this weekend you guys were [ __ ]
savages thank you full of love thank you
for having my back but most importantly
thank you for being a [ __ ] Savage
besides that it's a beautiful [ __ ]
week to be alive I got a new hairdo I'm
shooting a movie on Thursday they want
me to look like I'm [ __ ] 30 so they
dyed my hair into [ __ ] black in them
and I don't give a [ __ ] you know me I'm
still swinging dick and giving out
toothpicks it's a beautiful day you're
gonna make it happen
Church tonight 8 o'clock Church
Wednesday 8 o'clock and beside that way
here and we'll queer I got 2 different
types of weed today as usual this
perennial [ __ ] here and I got
this death on 2 legs here
enough with the chili chili Joey let's
get down and spark a number
oh yeah that's the way they do it on the
[ __ ] Monday get your lungs in shape
get it all together North Bergen New
Jersey I love your [ __ ] with
all my heart you understand me
you [ __ ] created a monster when
you made Joe Diaz at first I was a
[ __ ] loser thief and now I'm a loser
[ __ ] comic so you made it [ __ ]
happen beside that we're here we're
queer it's gonna be a phenomenal week
but the rest is up to you if you want to
be a [ __ ] more to doubt and hang out
with a bunch of other [ __ ]
mortadella's then that's what you're
gonna get if you're gonna put yourself
around the people that [ __ ] matter
and they're doing things and you take
the best parts of what they're doing and
take it into your life you can't [ __ ]
lose but Joey what's with the [ __ ]
sermon let's park this [ __ ] oh
yeah
I've got a couple things on the books
today I gotta go see a man about a dog I
gotta talk to the [ __ ] lawyer not
this second woman in Seattle so we can
go to Cuba in other places oh [ __ ] the
second Bowl of the session I hope you
guys are ready to cuz I'm taking [ __ ]
hostages [ __ ]
there you go that's the [ __ ] that kill
[ __ ] powers booth anyway I love you
[ __ ] it's that type of week you
got to make it happen what are you gonna
do sit there and let life pass you by
I may ask you a question when you see a
guy with a boat or a ship and he's got
[ __ ] dancing and they're naked he's
got blond he's doing do you think life
his life just happened do you think that
no no he made moobs for that to make
happen he worked for that even though
he's a [ __ ] stiff like I was doing
blow and being a [ __ ] animal you what
you put yourself in that position I live
a life right now I don't see no drama I
got a wife and a kid I sit here sometime
scratch my head and go how the [ __ ] can
I [ __ ] get here but you know what for
20 [ __ ] years I worked to get here
this is all about work people ain't
nobody gonna hand you a [ __ ] thing if
that's what you're thinking you're
mistakenly wrong when I was 21 I thought
I'll be bartending and somebody was
gonna come and discover me and put me in
movies and give me a CEO job that [ __ ]
only happens in the [ __ ] movies you
understand me you know pretty women
she's a [ __ ] hole with you she gonna
bump into [ __ ] Johnny Bananas and
he's gonna sail away that [ __ ] only
happens in the movies if you got a
rotten [ __ ] got a rotten [ __ ] how am I
gonna marry
but again you got to work for your life
brother whatever you want is gonna take
these and you're gonna work on different
parts and all of a sudden all the parts
come together you have a [ __ ] life
you have a life that you'd have to look
behind your shoulder you don't have to
[ __ ] now pick up the phone you know
even though I still look behind my
shoulder I got a couple edibles in me I
get [ __ ] creepy
who the [ __ ] is this page you're me at
5:46 in the morning crack of dawn and
now I'm yawning wipe the cold that my
see who's this pager mate and why anyway
little biggie for you [ __ ] on
Monday let's finish this [ __ ] cuz I'm
making a weed run anyway at 10:01 a.m.
I'm making a [ __ ] weed run because
that's it's Monday yeah they're gonna
see the one i jus
he's got no weed this week he calls his
[ __ ] eye shadow he says your eyeball
just [ __ ] shadow from the heat in
your brain that's what I'm [ __ ]
smoking the rest of the weekend Durst
and me plus me got the Stars it that
star one plus we got [ __ ] chocolates
we got we got everything we got a method
a dual hall and [ __ ] company
understand me beside that we got a
beautiful day you're gonna make it
happen it's gonna take time though don't
get discouraged you know you're not
gonna make a [ __ ] million [ __ ]
dollars in two days it's gonna take time
you got to work your head to get to the
head and then BAM you starts
bitch-slapping [ __ ] like Bruce
Lee and 71
I'm gonna get my Monday morning
shoutouts to my main man Ryan [ __ ]
our way over there and little Timmy jr.
and Secaucus my man lubes and North
Bergen always [ __ ] holding tight
kooky spooky clio Charlie looking good
via night up there and [ __ ] Canada
you know you [ __ ] come on I
want to give a hug to my main man Larry
in Vegas if anybody needs a hug it's my
man Larry but [ __ ] these tougher than
nails that [ __ ] but so he got
Larry pills he's ready for another month
besides that you know I love every one
of you big family
[ __ ] it her J Rama who showed up the
other night that [ __ ] some
chicks
some chick left him they think J Rama
sad damn cry [ __ ] no he came to see his
uncle [ __ ] joke my little sweet blonde
over there in Detroit is my man Marco
over the Chophouse in Milwaukee give me
a [ __ ] Lenny Bruce I'm live from the
Carnegie Hall there's a type of church
family we have we're family Doug I don't
need no fans you want fans go [ __ ]
hell with somebody else I don't my fans
I want a family I never had a family and
this is what I'm putting together right
now I'm working hard to put together a
nationwide refle family you can't stop
us they're gonna call us to reef is you
understand me
whoops let's do one more what the [ __ ]
that's my plan this summer we'll plan on
having a [ __ ] Church Oh what's
happening now festival with fooled
reefer magicians for three days podcast
and stand-up smoking dope and eatin
that's what the church does and plotting
the [ __ ] take holes we understand in
case this regime fails and these
[ __ ] want to come over we got
the church to fall back on you
understand me
how you like that [ __ ] apples that's
war preparing here
I'm beside this that's it and that's
that my man RJ Madden for [ __ ] taking
my food recommendations you know I love
all you [ __ ] i watch you you
don't think I'm watching but I'm
watching you Leon over there and [ __ ]
England [ __ ] and Spain what a [ __ ] he
is Germany handicapped and [ __ ]
[ __ ] playing cards Leon knows how to
do it Leon Vega follow Leon Vega we're
gonna [ __ ] live [ __ ] so that's
it that's that you accomplish your goal
you thought Joey [ __ ] up to the guilt
this morning this Christ my balls look
like yeah is [ __ ] Frankie Edgar close
those [ __ ] things shout out to
Frankie shout out to [ __ ] him ste OPIC
over there and [ __ ] clean that's my
[ __ ] it's the open kitchen
you're going down listen right now he's
sending brought where's no telegram
telling that [ __ ]
stock up on steroids [ __ ] if you don't
come to me I'm coming to you you [ __ ]
big-headed [ __ ] watch my mess
steep based arts [ __ ] slapping
[ __ ] you got my sexy savage
down there Johanna kitchen tree can take
whatever her [ __ ] name
she just confuses me that how little
polish savage with a little painted
[ __ ] fingernails she smashed you in
the face with painted fingernails who
does that type of [ __ ] not even a [ __ ] on
a Friday smash in the face with [ __ ]
painted fingernails
when that's dead not that I love you
[ __ ] you know I do I ain't no
fake [ __ ] one of these [ __ ] I'm uncle
Joey blue collar felon North Bergen to
the [ __ ] match understand me that's
how we do it that's what I want to
perceive that's what I'm like you
[ __ ] to perceive [ __ ] all this
Hollywood [ __ ] I'm just a dirty
[ __ ] stand up you understand me
[ __ ] I love you [ __ ] take
the world by the balls okay
don't let these [ __ ] buck [ __ ]
with you as they say don't let the man
get you down [ __ ] the man [ __ ] the man
okay with a [ __ ] man don't let
these [ __ ] get you down
all right [ __ ] em all up the ass the
Churchill what's happening now 8:00 p.m.
next Thursday I'm doing a little workout
ten bucks at the ice house Thursday
little room just [ __ ] try a new [ __ ]
I got to build my new [ __ ] savagery
for 2017 don't forget tonight
don't forget tonight a p.m. the Church
of what's happened now youtube.com slash
C / Joey Diaz have a great day keep your
eyes open Isis is out there and remember
ain't nobody better than you
[ __ ] love you